quelques espérances album que dit elle
je lui dit seigneur
ma foi je n'ai pas la peine de le
répéter mais comme cela c'est bien je
suis votre amour vous êtes ma maîtresse
retenez le bien car cela est vrai et
tant que je serai en vie cela ira
toujours le même pain cela ne prendra
pas je me remets compagnie avec cela
assadi 3 le serment que vous voulez que
je vous fasse à qui va bien je me suis
prêté serment
j'ai votre amitié vous avez la mienne je
ne la reprendrais pas à kiev que
j'apporterai tête ou pas le plus joli
garçon qu'il y ait gatti quelques filles
qui vous vous aimez autant que moi et
bien n'est ce pas assez nous en faut-il
davantage
il n'y a qu'à rester comme ne sommes il
n'y aura pas besoin de serment dansante
est issu nous serons toujours beau leur
seigneur vous pouvez en toute sûreté
ordonné les après de votre mariage vous
arrangez pour cela je vous garantis et
mais je voulais anti marié sylvia va
vous donner son coeur ensuite sa main je
l'entendis si vous dire je vous aime je
vois vos noces
elles se font harlequins me pose vous
aimerez de vaux bien fait et voilà
qu'ils fissent
ce sont des lettres de noblesse pour le
poisson gratifie comme parents disent
ils car on dit que vous êtes un peu oui
je suis jalouse il est vrai mais puisque
vous l'aimez pas de presse et une loi à
leur mettre dans les dispositions j'ai
cru qu'il était pour moi il est sûr que
je ne déplaisait pas et je le dis vive
évacuation qui l'attend vous si vous me
laissez faire elle ne saurait se passer
de la plante on demeure il ya deux ans
et dans lequel il ya deux ans que je
soupire en secret pour elle
vous m'étonnez je suis enchantée vous
répéter ça autrement voilà que je vous
aime cela est décidé je n'y comprends
rien est ce que vous êtes le prince
oui s'il vient
[Rires]
quelle aventure
[Musique]